we have not forgotten about the death of
Washington Post journalist Jamal
khashoggi at the hands of the Saudi
Arabian consulate in Istanbul Turkey and
you might recall that on October 2nd
Khashoggi disappeared he was last seen
entering the embassy we received
multiple conflicting stories from Saudi
Arabia and I'm having trouble even
remembering the full sequence I think
the first story from Saudi Arabia was we
don't know anything at all about
anything shogi
Istanbul consulate we don't know
anything at all at some point the story
from Saudi Arabia
I believe changed too he did go to the
consulate but he left very quickly and
we don't know anything else and it could
have been rogue killers if indeed he
ended up dead which we don't even know
and Donald Trump actually ended up
parroting that one that it could be
rogue killers and of course we now know
that it wasn't then the story became
okay yeah he was at the consulate and he
was actually interrogated by Saudi
officials and the interrogation went
wrong and he ended up accidentally dead
horrible thing just an accident
no big deal then the story from the
Saudis changed - well actually Khashoggi
got into a fight at the Embassy and he
ended up dead and reportedly dismembered
as well and that was maybe the least
believable of all the stories which
showed us that it really was getting
very very bad because it's really
difficult to believe that a 59 year old
man would choose to start a fight with
15 people and end up not only dead but
also taken apart and then reportedly put
the potentially dissolved in acid in a
scene reminiscent of Breaking Bad but
with his remains destroyed as the term
is okay forget about all that stuff
because we now have a new report from
Turkish investigators who have been
looking into this remember it was the
Saudi embassy in Istanbul Turkey turkey
now has put out a report saying that
Jamal Khashoggi was strangled to death
as soon as he entered the Saudi
consulate
an interrogation gone wrong not a fight
which ended up with him dead strangled
almost immediately upon walking into the
Saudi consulate followed by the
dismembering and as I mentioned
destruction of his body these are words
directly from the Turkish report number
one these Saudis are total liars
right we've now gotten five stories from
them all of which are reportedly false
number two it seems Turkey actually has
a lot more information than they were
initially willing to let on number three
the Saudi stories weren't believable
from day one but what's stunning to me
is that they came up at some point with
the it was a fight and he ended up dead
that was the best story they could come
up with after like the first three or
four stories were clearly found to not
be true imagine the stories they opted
not to tell that is really really scary
and also sort of hilarious but hilarious
only in the context that we laugh
instead of cry and then remember that
the Saudi sent out a body double wearing
Jamal khashoggi clothes to create a fake
surveillance camera trail and when you
realize that they did that when you
realized that they had a body double put
on Khashoggi x' clothes and walk in
front of a surveillance camera then you
realize that these are the perpetrators
the Saudis are not the people trying to
figure out what's going on and that's
why this situations details aside people
like Trump and duterte and the others
the distaste for a prepress because
that's what got Khashoggi on the radar
of the Saudis he was writing articles in
The Washington Post that were critical
of the regime that were calling for
reforms and the Saudis didn't like that
that's why pat when I see the contempt
for a free press from Donald Trump when
I see the contempt for a pre Free Press
from Rodrigo Duterte
that's why it's so scary because it's
not that many steps further between
between from merely trying to say
Rast journalistic speech to actually
encouraging or even participating in
violence against the media and after the
death of khashoggi Trump did have an
opportunity to come out in support of a
free press I mean maybe he thinks that
for the most part it's all fun and games
because people don't typically get
killed even though he does bash the
media a day to day this would have been
the one time to say that we have to
support our Fourth Estate and we have to
make sure that journalists are protected
and not killed by anyone be it rogue
killers or the Saudi government yeah and
unfortunately the exact opposite
happened right I mean Trump was very
very clear that he wasn't going to let a
cold-blooded government murder of a
journalist working for The Washington
Post get in the way of an arms deal get
in the way of the hand-holding and
kissing but the with the Saudi royal
family and get in the way of this sort
of relationship that comes in part
because of the desire for shared
stability for stability in the Middle
Middle East a shared desire for that
much of it relating to the oil markets
we have a history of placating and
arming narcissistic extremists
authoritarian regimes like that of Saudi
Arabia it's clear we're going to keep
doing that and earlier this week I spoke
to congressman ro Khanna if we elect
more people like him maybe we'll be able
to actually do something about this but
it's not looking good because nothing so
far four years I mean I've been talking
about this problem for nearly ten years
the Saudi problem specifically and it's
been going on much longer than that
nothing has made any significant
progress at interfering with this
depraved and vile relationship I don't
even know that I call it an alliance
even though it's strictly speaking is
this relationship with one of the most
authoritarian extremist regimes in the
world right now
make sure that you followed the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show follow me as well while you're at
it at David Pakman on Instagram today's
show was made possible in part by Sion
Games and their new game for phone and
tablet called ant
which is an award-winning strategy game
it's all about using vaccines to defend
the human body from bacteria and viruses
it's fast paced the graphics are amazing
the game has actually been commended by
the World Health Organization because it
has a mission to fight back against anti
vaccine misinformation so the game is
educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on youtube i've put the
links under the video